I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight trial by
error that's the focus of tonight's
angle and now you might be asking why is
public trust in the American Judicial
System declining well it's not simply
the BLM propaganda flooding our schools
our universities that's told young
people that disproportionate
incarceration of African-Americans
equals racism it's not just that respect
for our justice system is also cratering
due to Democrats Crusade both against
Trump and against traditional Americans
in general now for the most egregious
example look no further than Trump's
Civil Trial in New York brought by Trump
hating activist Leticia James now
yesterday judge Arthur angeron who looks
like any random legal panelist on MSNBC
blatantly revealed his anti-trump bias
for the world to see because he went so
far as to mock Trump's phrase about the
perfect phone call
even using air quotes as he said it now
a conversation with the president let me
just get this right a conversation that
the president had with zalinski is
somehow fair game for a fraud trial that
deals with actions years ago look I saw
this and I thought look nobody will be
surprised by this this guy's a lefty
going back to his days as an
anti-vietnam War protester we all know
what's going on here no case like this
has ever been brought in New York
overvaluing assets and they're bringing
it now only to try to break Trump
financially and we know if Trump never
ran for president they never would have
targeted him never would have happened
that's undeniable and it's Prima fascia
evidence of the rank political Vendetta
at work here now the media has made it
very clear to any Democrat and the doj
or the DA's offices around the country
that their job is to prosecute Joe
Biden's political opponent by any means
necessary they don't want equal
application of the law that's why there
are no cries for prosecuting those
pramas nutbags who damaged White House
property and historic monuments last
weekend now imagine if it had been
conservative protesters who tried to
scale the White House fence or who
splattered paint on the gates think of
the resources that would have been
devoted to arresting every last
suspect well we already have a pretty
good idea don't we of how they handle
protests that they don't approve of they
do things like carry out early morning
raids on the homes of elderly January 6
suspects who committed no acts of
violence and 6 o00 in the morning I hear
Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom FBI open the
door open the door we'll knock it down
or and one was pointing an assault rifle
at my head about 4 ft away and they said
please step outside I stepped outside
they handcuffed me me I said what is
this about and they said search warrant
they never produced one they never
showed it at 9:00 in the morning I am on
my bed doing my emails which I usually
do I can hear some Ruckus going on in
the other room the K so I get up come
around the corner and I hear somebody
barking hands up FBI they proceeded to
handcuff me gave me no reasons why of
course no search warrant God forbid they
present a search warrant and they all
they also launched a m massive made for
TV Manhunt this happens almost two years
after January 6th morning the FBI says
they arrested a January 6 defendant
after a major police
Manhunt yeah that's right he was a New
Jersey National Guard member who was
charged with felonies in connection with
the January 6th attack he was there at
the capital Gregory Yetman is his name
when the FBI went to arrest him he fled
and there was a massive Manhunt in New
Jersey how many times can they say
massive Manhunt okay this week just to
give you a sense of the resources spent
federal state and local law enforcement
yeah huge resources were used in this
attempt to arrest this former New Jersey
National Guardsman who' been uh wanted
for allegedly picking up a can of pepper
spray and using it against Capitol
Police and other protesters so this guy
Gregory Yetman was 46 years of age
turned himself in without incident but
the FBI made its Point didn't it and by
the way this was all done to arrest an
individual who the local mayor said was
no threat to the community which begs
the question why did they need to deploy
SWAT teams police canines calling the
helicopters roadblocks all that why do
they need to do that well many Americans
get it right they see it for what it is
this is a two-tiered system of justice
arresting this guy with such a big
display of force is the message to all
of you not worth attending a rally any
kind of rally now was it in any way
proportional or that the head of the
proud boys who wasn't even at the
capital on January 6 was handed a
sentence of 22 years in federal prison
the prosecutor said that the sentence
was meant to deter others who were quote
unhappy with the results of future
elections huh well how many fentanyl
drug dealers whose pills have killed
people get that kind of sense just last
month the dealer linked to the deadly
pills so sold to actor Michael K will
Williams He Got amley 5 years in federal
prison 5 years for selling a deadly drug
that killed a
man so we have gang members we got drug
dealers rapists child molesters
murderers and perhaps even terrorists
who've crossed our Southern border and
yet the Biden Administration they don't
came to say seem to care about that
there's 280 something people on the
terrorist watch list are they out of the
country or they in the country country
senator they very well may be out of the
country but you don't
know but they know where those January 6
people are they just don't care about
the Border crossers because that
narrative is bad for them politically
yet not so with the January 6 cases
because they're key to Biden's campaign
thus the doj is still expending massive
resources on those cases we've seen
about a, 200 cases thus far but a thous
other people have been identified and on
top of that you got a thousand others
who are unidentified yet who could face
charges and the statute of limitations
expires in early
20126 look as long as the Democrats
think that this helps them politically
they're going to keep the charade going
when true threats to society Run free
this simply makes us trust them less
though if that's possible at this point
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page age and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else